so ist es und heute mit einem Aufreger
der was mit Journalismus zu tun hat den
Bild hat was unglaubliches gemacht in
den beginnenden Sondierungsgesprächen
wir und vor allen Dingen mein Kollege
Paul ronsheimer hat einfach berichtet er
hat berichtet über das was dahinter
verschlossenen Türen passiert ist Handy
Alarm haben wir das getauft bei Bild
aber es sagt nichts anderes als das Paul
Informationen bekommen hat aus diesen
vertraulichen Sitzungen und diese an Sie
weitergegeben hat und sie jetzt Karin
Prien nämlich diese hier eingeblendet
sehen die Bildungsministerin von
Schleswig-Holstein und sie war ja auch
in zukunftsteam von Armin Laschet die
will dem ganzen ein Ende bereiten klar
die ist total genervt davon dass ihre
Parteikollegen immer so viel
Informationen weitergeben aber sie
möchte das Radikal beendet in dem sie
sagt weg mit den Mobiltelefonen aus
vertraulichen Sitzungen und zwar sofort
also sie möchte ein Handyverbot für ihre
cdu-kollegen und CDU Kollegen
durchsetzen das ist mehr grünen Politik
als Unionspolitik Verbotspolitik die
quaranthrin dadurch setzen möchte und
ich sage das ist vor allem eins das ist
peinlich für die eigenen Reihen denn es
zeigt wie groß das Misstrauen ist bei
der Union da traut der eine dem anderen
nicht mehr am Tisch und das einzige was
quarantin einfällt ist am Ende zu sagen
weg mit den Handys Handyverbot für alle
Methoden wie in der Schule wie die Union
dazu erziehen sollen nicht mehr so
misstrauisch sich selbst gegenüber zu
sein ein unglaubliche Forderung die da
aus Schleswig-Holstein kommt die aus der
CDU kommt und die wie gesagt nur eines
verdeutlicht das unglaubliche Misstrauen
im Moment in der CDU ich finde dass das
bestätigt ja auch so ein bisschen das
Misstrauen was in der Bevölkerung
entstanden ist gegenüber der Politik
auch gegenüber der CDU und ich meine
sind wir hier in der Schule erstens
zweitens ist es auch ein Einschnitt in
die journalistische Freiheit und
außerdem ist ja auch der Verdacht oder
dieser dieses dieser Vorwurf in der
Politik das alles immer hinter
verschlossenen Türen geschieht ist immer
das ist mein Vater mir gesagt hat ja die
die reden da immer irgendwie irgendwas
in ihren Hinterzimmern Gesprächen und
man man erfahrt das irgendwie eh nicht
und natürlich verstehe ich es wenn man
als Politiker auch mal vertrauliche
Gespräche führen will muss man ja auch
um sich geschlossen auch ja besprechen
zu können und und auch mal diesen
Denkprozess anzustoßen aber das was
Karin Prien jetzt beschlossen oder
angestoßen hat finde ich schon sehr
lächerlich es ist ja auch absolut naiv
also wenn ich Handyverbot in einer
Sitzung habe
gibt in der heutigen Zeit so viele
Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten vielleicht
auch nach einer Sitzung also auch das zu
glauben dass das nur innerhalb einer
Sitzung geht also das ist naiv karibrin
hat natürlich in diesem Beitrag auch
gesagt und das spricht am Ende dann auch
wieder ein bisschen für Sie das
natürlich das was da gerade passiert
sagt über den Zustand ihrer eigenen
Partei und wir sehen es ist eine der
erodieren gerade die Machtverhältnisse
sehr interessant dass bei SPD grün und
FDP Parteien die jetzt bei der
Bundestagswahl mehr oder weniger sehr
erfolgreich abgeschnitten haben diese
Dinge nicht passieren aber dass wir es
bei der Union sehen wo einfach jetzt die
Macht erodiert und diese Partei muss
sich erstmal selbst finden und selbst
suchen und dabei muss man vielleicht
auch den Frustfaktor den Karin Prien
gerade hat nicht ganz außer acht lassen
Karin Prien bei Mitglied des
zukunftsteams Karin Prien wurde immer
schon auch als Ministerin gehandelt wäre
sicherlich auch gerne Bundesministerin
geworden einem Kabinett von Armin
Laschet kann es nur nicht werden jetzt
gibt es sogar erste Stimmen die sagen ja
kein Primzahl neue Generalsekretärin der
CDU werden also möglicherweise da will
ich niemand Verdächtigen aber kommt
diese Information sogar aus ihrem
eigenen Umfeld also vielleicht lässt
sich das sogar streuen weiß ich nicht
will ich deswegen auch nicht mutmaßen
aber es interessant das ist noch gar
kein neuen Parteichef gibt aber eine
neue Generalsekretärin offenbar schon im
Gespräch ist also das ist ja wirklich
als wenn der Hund im Schwanz Bild also
man sieht Karin Prien ist frustriert wer
gerne mehr geworden und so buche ich das
ab als totale Frustration total Haufen
echt ich finde es also was ich spannend
finde an der ganzen Geschichte jetzt mit
äh ich habe die doch nicht gewählt also
das ist eine Eier wen haben Sie jetzt
gewählt haben die CDU gewählt oder nicht
ständig
okay Olaf Scholz gewählt aber Olaf
Scholz Sparbuch schon
21:05 Uhr
was ich sagen wollte was ich spannend
finde jetzt bemerke im Grunde sich
zurückzieht merkt man dass es auch immer
schon Stimmen gab die sich hervor tun
wollen die jetzt irgendwie nie gehört
wurden oder zumindest jetzt erst diese
aufmerksamkeitsschwelle bekommen und das
ist genau das das Ding ist dass die
Machtverhältnisse sich jetzt gerade
einfach verändern und noch gar nicht so
ganz klar ist
ich werde am Ende auch die
Aufmerksamkeit auf eine
Aufmerksamkeitsspanne auch langfristig
halten kann aber
ich also wir können es nur abwarten und
wir wissen nicht was in vier fünf
Monaten oder generell die CDU eine
Opposition für Menschen hervorbringt die
jetzt jahrelang ich sag mal er still
waren und sich zurückgehalten haben
Misstrauen ist natürlich keine
unionsphänomen das muss man auch mal
ehrlich sagen wo vertraut man sich
eigentlich hier im politischen Berlin
wenn es wirklich hart auf hart kommt
also nehmen wir dieses selfie was wir
gesehen haben zwischen FDP und Grün das
soll ja Vertrauen symbolisieren fast
eine freundschaftliche Atmosphäre da an
dem Dienstagabend nach der Wahl und wenn
man jetzt aber sich eine Situation
spitzt auf Knopf vorstellen würde ob
irgendjemand von den vieren dem Nachbar
auf dem Foto auch nur eine Sekunde über
den Weg traut
sie würde ich sehr im Zweifel ziehen
einfach dieses diese Art von Vertrauen
nicht es gibt gemeinsame Interessen und
deswegen hält man bei der FDP im Moment
auch still deswegen hält man bei der bei
den Grünen im Moment auch still aber
eben nur so lange wie man dieselben
Interessen hat das ändert sich sofort
wenn die FDP dann tatsächlich auf dem
Ampel Kurs ist wenn man über
Steuererhöhungen mit der SPD diskutieren
muss und so weiter da entgleitet das
dann auch und bei der SPD ganz genauso
mit Norbert Walter bojans und Saskia
esken die laufen sich jetzt schon warm
und haben jetzt schon die Handynummer
von Paul rausgesucht um die Infos
draufzusetzen
die schöne Steigerung Feind totfeind
Parteifreund
aber wir müssen ja hier glaube ich schon
mal sagen ich erinnere das schon so ein
bisschen an so früher in der Schule wenn
irgendwie ich dreimal aufgefordert wurde
weil ich wieder zu viel Zettelchen mit
meiner Nachbarin geschrieben habe sitzen
Nachbarin ich meine wir reden über
WhatsApp ich meine wir reden über hohe
Politik und jetzt soll es ein
Handyverbot geben das ist für mich ein
Thema was auf Deutschland Schulhöfen
herrscht wenn der Lehrer mal richtig
irgendwie die auf den Tisch legt und
sagt jetzt reicht sie mit euren handys
alle Handy weg und dann die Eltern noch
hinlaufende Pausen sagen die können sie
meinem Sohn das Handy wegnehmen das ist
ein recht von ihm also ich finde es für
die Politik schon sehr peinlich ehrlich
alle Parteifreunde eigentlich stellt sie
unter Generalverdacht das muss man auch
sagen das ist also das muss man sich
dann mal bitten lassen wenn man da
irgendwie 20 oder 30 Jahre im Parlament
auch sitzt in dem Fall ein ganz
ehrlicher
Parteifreund ist oder eine Parteifreunde
ist und dann kommt jemand aus
Schleswig-Holstein sagt böse böse böse
wir sind alle unter Generalverdacht und
deswegen ab jetzt Handy aus also
zauberhaft vor ich stehe es mir so
Zauber hervor montags Sitzung des
Präsidiums Wolfgang Schäuble Volker
Bouffier die die Michael Kretschmer aus
Sachsen die ganzen Kranken fahren vor
und dann steht vorne Karin Prien oder
die Generalsekretär und sammelt erstmal
die Handys ein mit dem Körbchen aber man
kann dort petzen ohne Ende oder ich habe
jetzt auch kein Handy dabei und kann
dann irgendwas petzen was wir hier
gesagt haben
vorbei also aber Karin Prien hat in
ihrer Karriere auch immer davon
profitiert natürlich dass sie Dinge auch
mit Journalisten wir sagen es einfach
mal ganz neutral geteilt hat und
natürlich ist es wichtig und es ist der
Anspruch von uns Journalisten dass wir
Dinge herausbekommen es geht am Ende ja
darum wer will Deutschland regieren und
es ist Pflicht von Journalisten
aufzuklären auch zu schauen gerade
dorthin wo man versucht Informationen
fernzuhalten von der Öffentlichkeit
genau da zuschauen und zu sagen also
passiert da etwas was uns ein bisschen
komisch vorkommt müssen wir dann noch
näher hinschauen von daher ist das
eigentlich eine Verkehr der Tatsachen
und die ist dem eigenen Frust dem Frau
Prien jetzt schiebt geschuldet aber der
handy-alarm ist halt auch er sorgt schon
sehr für furoropholz Handy ja also ich
meine Deutschlandfunk hat jetzt auch
geschaut wie das jetzt mit dem Handy
Alarm ist ob das jetzt gut ist für die
Demokratie ich finde schon relativ
witzig wie viel dieser Handy Alarm
auslöst weil im Journalismus ist ja
schon ganz Deutschlandfunk jetzt gucken
will ob das gut ist für Demokratie das
wundert mich wieder mal gar nicht also
das sind nämlich überhaupt nicht
aber
neue daran für ein Großteil der
Journalisten ist dass wir nicht
ausschließlich warten auf Verlautbarung
auf die Statements Mitteilung sondern
dass wir sechs Nachrichten machen das
ist halt neu für den Rest der paul ist
jetzt eigentlich nur ein Symbol dafür
was sowieso überall passiert oder läuft
es ist ja eigentlich die Arbeit von
einem politikjournalisten Journalisten
dran sind um zu erfahren was wirklich in
den Sitzungen abgelaufen ist und das
finde ich halt auch sehr witzig dass
Karin Prinz
das heißt eigentlich für mich
echauffiert sie sich schon auch über den
Journalismus an sich sehr zwar später
noch mal richtig gestelltes ginge um die
Unionspolitiker aber so ich mag das
Handy von Paul ich finde es immer sehr
witzig bei anderen Kollegen ist es
möglicherweise der Neid dass diese
Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese
Informationen selbst nicht haben und
davor offenbar entweder Toten Handys
oder ausgeschalteten Handys oder Türen
stehen durch die sie nicht kommen dass
das muss man einfach so sehen aber die
Debatte darum ob das jetzt gut oder
schlecht für die Demokratie und für die
Freiheit ist das ist wirklich die
absurdeste Debatte des Jahres also das
Informationen das Licht der Welt
erblicken über die Frage was wird in
einem runden diskutiert wenn es um die
Zukunft von Deutschland geht das ist das
darauf hat jeder der 82 Millionen
Bundesbürger ein Anrecht könnte ein
Menschenrecht könnte man die
Verhandlungen eigentlich komplett
transparent führen Livestream könnte
könnte man das machen es wäre doch ein
wahnsinnig faszinierender Ansatz
blauer verkauft oder was machen die da
konstruieren die jetzt da draußen ich
glaube es passiert einfach gar nichts
also die quaranthrin setzt ihr
Handyverbot nicht durch und die
Informationen werden weiter auf Pauls
Handy landen
machen
[Musik]